I think I've been a senior three times
I'm pretty sure the kids will have
graduated maybe actually we get held
Becky yeah I don't want the kids to be
in high school forever we are now in our
senior year at Riverdale high what does
this mean for the future of the show how
much longer do you see it going on as
long as the fans keep watching I mean
the show tional Colegrove Adele hi it's
called Riverdale so you never know what
can happen off to it that is a perfect
answer
maybe I T would get held Becky yeah I
mean he didn't really go to school much
his junior year I would not be surprised
I'm surprised he passed junior year are
you sure he's a senior I mean obviously
damn I mean this is senior year season
four once he's in four wraps I'm pretty
sure that kids will have graduated so as
far as where it goes from here I don't
know I think there's opportunities for
the kids to leave Riverdale but there's
also opportunities for them to stay and
I think there's a lot of unfinished
business for a lot of them and it seems
like they might all feel the need to
stay and take care of things with their
family or with their businesses you know
obviously Veronica has like 12
businesses that she's running yeah I
think Betty probably wants to stay close
to her mom and at least for a little
while they've got some stuff to figure
out I think they're all gonna take a
break year gap year and like just chill
for a minute 100 percent I think I've
been a senior three times once in real
life and twice on television I think one
of the initial questions for the
abstract of the show was are we going to
age over time and you know naturally as
we grow older and we look older we had
to solve that problem so it's nice that
that we're aging and it also kind of
frees up the universe a little bit
inside Riverdale to play around with
that concept I'm excited to see where we
all go is that enough proof for you I
don't want the kids to be in high school
forever I think Riverdale is very much a
show about the cycle of life and things
you know growing up and all of that so I
think it's it'd be really cool to see
them go off to college and grow up and
see what they make out of their lives
and maybe the show ends with someone
having a kid you know who knows I which
I'm just pitching things I'm just like
hoping our showrunner
you know all the varchar fans are like
it's happening yeah not a drill she's a
crazy as fan things what is the craziest
fan theory or idea that they're trying
to type hitch provides about fan
theories really but I do see a lot of
like fan fiction or just kind of like
but my guess guess that wasn't even the
characters that was just my personal
life's never mind but I do know that
he's got a really weird woman that was
like all the way to like me and
Madeleine we're both having babies and
like talking I was just like a really
weird fanfic sure how many more secret
children should we be expecting
[Music]